the mother of dragons hasn't been the
same since she conquered Westeros
ever since Emilia Clarke wrapped up her
role as Daenerys Targaryen on HBO's hit
series Game of Thrones she has spoken
out about some of the tougher moments
she faced both on and off screen
throughout her incredibly challenging
decade-long role the actor survived
plenty of harrowing times no matter how
much fame and acclaim she racked up in
the time since Game of Thrones came to a
fiery conclusion Emilia Clarke has been
extraordinarily forthcoming about some
of the biggest struggles she dealt with
during filming in short it's not hard to
understand why she hasn't fully
recovered from Game of Thrones as a
fresh-faced are on a huge HBO show
Emilia Clarke seemed destined for
stardom thanks to her performance as
Daenerys however it wasn't until the
spring of 2019 that fans realized just
how much personal comfort she truly
sacrificed for the role in a New Yorker
piece that ran in March of that year
Clarke admitted that she suffered two
debilitating brain injuries while
filming the first two seasons of Game of
Thrones both of which could have ended
her career and life after experiencing a
serious brain aneurysm right after she
wrapped filming on the show's freshman
season Clarke thankfully recovered but
was left frightened depressed and
anxious about whether or not she would
be able to continue working the actress
suffered from aphasia a condition that
renders one unable to speak correctly in
the aftermath of the first aneurysm
during the show's second season she
suffered from serious anxiety and
collapsed once then endured yet another
aneurysm after the third season of
Thrones wrapped at that time Clarke was
also preparing for her Broadway debut
and Breakfast at Tiffany's Clarke's
co-stars including Khal Drogo actor
Jason Momoa were incredibly supportive
of her speaking out about what she'd
been through but the experience was
terrifying for the young actress in the
same article Clarke revealed that she
sank to a dark place after her second
aneurysm all hope receded I felt like a
shell of myself so much so that I now
have a hard time remembering those dark
days in much detail my mind has blocked
him out but I do remember being
convinced that it wasn't going to live
beyond her frightening off-screen
medical struggles Emilia Clarke also
endured plenty of hardships on the set
of Game of Thrones as the star of the
show that was routinely called out for
unnecessary nudity Clark was
unsurprisingly asked to perform a number
of nude scenes she was often
uncomfortable on set and unsure if she
could say no
till later seasons once she gained more
clout and recognition in November two
thousand nineteen she admitted that some
of her nude scenes were difficult to
handle particularly because she felt
both powerless and pressured as a young
performer on the cusp of international
stardom
however with or without the nude scenes
Clark also suffered from serious
imposter syndrome on the set of Thrones
during the show's early seasons as she
told Dax Shepard on his podcast armchair
expert regardless of whether they'd be
nudity or not I would have spent that
first season thinking I'm not worthy of
requiring anything I'm not worthy of
needing anything at all beyond that
Daenerys Targaryen journey left emilia
clark understandably shaken as well
the actress spent years playing her
character is a virtuous Justice driven
young queen hell-bent on reclaiming her
family's ancestral throne that's why a
shot Clarke just as much as anyone else
when Daenerys torched King's Landing
from atop her largest dragon in the
final season the decision led to her
murdering countless innocent civilians
in her quest to take the Iron Throne
Clarke admitted that upon reading the
script and learning of the big Daenerys
twist she had to walk around the streets
of London just to process the characters
personal arc that shock was undoubtedly
made even worse considering that after
sacking King's Landing Danny doesn't
make it to the Iron Throne instead she's
assassinated by her nephew lover Jon
Snow Clarke will likely always be
associated with Daenerys Targaryen that
even game of thrones' biggest fans
should recognize the sacrifices the
actor made for this enormous
unforgettable role check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite actors
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]